I am someone who wakes up in a different
body every day always someone my age
never the same person twice I have
absolutely no control over any of it
it's not possible it is every day of
your life you've just woken up and just
try to live that day for that person why
are you doing this day we met I felt
something I've never felt before
[Music]
I'm a moment someone who wakes up in a
different body every day always the same
age never the same person twice think
about what happens if you and I stay
together we can make it work I want to
believe that
[Music]
what will happen to your life if I'm the
person in the world that you're closest
to you know I thought you'd left left
I'd never leave other than everyday
it all started with this incredible book
that David Levithan rode I loved the
book and so then like two years later
when my agent sent me an email about
this film that was being made I was like
oh oh I've read this this is so cool
this would be awesome as a movies I fell
in love with the book I told David this
he came to said the other day the way he
can empathize with a bunch of different
types of people is incredible and for
the movie it really has been interesting
to see the perspective of a from the
outside first question I asked was how
he going to show a I loved Michael's
response he said yeah we're just gonna
get 10 different actors to play the same
person it's gonna be fantastic to see on
screen one of the things that Jesse
Andrews did is to change the perspective
from a to Rhiannon so when you're
talking about Rihanna's role you need to
see more than just her interactions with
a she's still trying to figure out who
she is and how to define herself not in
terms of her family she becomes more
confident about who she is and she comes
into her own what's important in
adapting a book is to recreate the
experience you go through and reading
the book it's been really wonderful to
see it come to life
when they fall into words the ideas
behind it are all very real to all the
actors and everybody involved
[Music]